in his remarks after the ruling
president biden said the supreme court's
decision must not be the final word on
abortion he directly linked the decision
to the upcoming midterm elections today
president biden travels to germany for
the g7 summit where he will discuss
global economic issues but the shock
waves of overturning roe will follow him
on this foreign trip cbs news senior
white house and political correspondent
ed o'keefe is just over the austrian
border from where that meeting will
occur and joins us now ed let's start
with that political fallout the
president even said this won't be the
last word what might we see in those
midterms coming up
well dana good to see you i think the
biggest impact at least initially is
going to be on state races races for
governor and control of state
legislatures now that this is a state by
state decision watch states especially
where there might be a democratic
governor and a republican state
legislature places like michigan and
pennsylvania beyond that it's a reminder
that elections have consequences and at
the federal level you're going to see
democrats and republicans talking about
things like passing a law that allows
abortion rights nationally or
republicans talking about a law that
would ban it nationally it's going to be
among the issues they discuss as they
try to either hold on to or take control
of congress
at overturning overturning roe v wade
has long been a goal of conservatives is
there an indication what you think
you've been talking to them what what do
they look to next
well now they're going to have to sort
out how exactly to define what is
permissible in each of these states
where for example a trigger law might be
about to take effect uh or or they're
going to put restrictions in place you
know at what point is the ban in place
is it 15 weeks is it less than that is
it more than that what's the definition
of viability uh when when does life in
essence begin
what other services might a state be
willing to pay for now to help mothers
either who didn't want the pregnancy
can't afford to have the pregnancy or
are going to need assistance that's the
next step in this and it's going to be a
different definition from different
republican governors and state
legislatures across the country as jan
said earlier ultimately some of this
will end up being
sorted out by the courts but that won't
be for several more years but to watch
them now deal with this issue of
restricting it and what the definitions
are that's going to be tricky for the
conservative movement for republicans
overall because the answer is going to
be different state to state
ed this has been a momentous week with
gun legislation
this this supreme court ruling and the
january sixth hearings i mean what is
your take away
well michelle it's a reminder elections
have consequences and if you're somebody
who's thrilled with what happened this
week or terrified by what happened this
week
it's a reminder you have an obligation
you have an ability a right to get up
and do something about it by voting or
participating in the process and those
that do so more often are the ones that
ultimately are going to prevail it's a
reminder too we work in a co-equal
system of government there are three
branches this week was a big week for
congress they passed a sweeping
bipartisan gun bill the supreme court
made some big rulings in terms of
abortion rights even miranda rights
arrest records
the president is going to sign that
bipartisan gun legislation this morning
and then come here to europe to conduct
the one thing that he's able to do and
that is foreign policy so it's a
reminder we live in a system where three
branches can make big decisions the
others will offset them and elections
have consequences it's also a reminder
that change takes time for those that
were pushing for the end of abortion
rights it took nearly five decades if
those uh who want to switch it back want
to do something about it it could take a
while and that'll be a challenge for
especially the democratic party as they
try to motivate people to turn out this
fall to say look it's it's going to take
a while but it requires showing up over
and over again to put people in place
yeah as you mentioned that time it'll be
interesting to see the impact of the
decision personally the impact immediate
but also the fallout as you mentioned
politically and economically that we may
see over even more time thank you for
the perspective and the insight